Okay, we have a uh 2017 Hyundai Santa
Cafe. We are going to add a key.
Initially, customer thought that this
key wasn't
working. Um I told them that it could be
a battery problem. So, I came on site
and uh checked. Sure enough, it was just
a battery problem. So, instead of a all
keys lost, we're just going to have to
add a key. So pretty quickly we are
going to switch the ignition on is that
key here. We are going to attempt to add
a uh an aftermarket key to it. Uh this
Hyundai Santa Fe have
uh keys that works on two different
frequency. Some of them work on 433 MHz
and some work on 350. This vehicle is
the one that works on the 315 MHz. I do
have two aftermarket keys here. Uh
Hyundai's vehicle are a little picky
about, you know, programming keys.
Sometimes they refuse aftermarket keys,
but I do trust this supplier. They
usually provide very good keys even
aftermarket. So, I'm going to try to add
this to the system. So, real quick, what
we're going to do is uh to identify the
vehicle. Uh I already have the Wi-Fi
turned on. We are going to click on this
and uh type Hyundai and we have Hyundai
here. I wanted to start with Lounor but
uh KM100 is pretty good at identifying
Hyundai's and Kia is pretty quick. Uh
the only issue I have with KM100 is uh
the time it takes to read the password.
So, let's try and find out. Uh
uh I do want to point out that the B the
the customer's battery
uh in the car is really low. Matter of
fact, the vehicle wouldn't start at
first. So now, actually, this is a
2015, but this key covers 2013 to 2017.
So, this is a smart key.
Okay. So, we are going to go into
control unit keyless radioizer password.
This is a ID8A ship. Let's try to do
that. Okay. Click on okay. Turn the
hazard
on. It's pretty hot in here. I was
hoping for the AC to be working, but
it's not working. It is normal. If the
ignition, if the instrument cluster turn
black, no worries. Uh, we open and close
the driver door right
now. And then we are going to click on
okay to start the
procedure.
Uh, it claims that the key is not into
the vehicle. For some reason, it didn't
detect it, but now it seems like
everything is okay. So, excuse the
glare, but this is the only spot that I
have to work. So, I'm just going to have
to do with
it. Password. I'm going to try to put a
uh
stopwatch just so I can
uh I can have an idea how long it took
me to read that
password
clock stopwatch on. We've been in this
process for already 1 minute. So, at the
end, we're just going to total this up
and find out how long it took. If it
reads the password, if KM 100 is taking
too long to read the password, I'm going
to try to disconnect the battery and uh
reconnect it. If that doesn't work, I'm
just going to use Lawn Door because by
experience, Lonesor is faster than
KM100 in my experience. We now have a
password. Remember we had uh been
looking for about 1 minute and plus the
countdown right now is 218. So all
together 3 minutes and uh 30 seconds. So
that's not too bad. So we are going to
go into the add key function.
So we are going to get out of
this function and then we are going to
go into keyless and remote control
learning. Okay, smart key
learning. I'm going to say yes.
Turn the hazard light on. It's already
turned on. Open and close the driver's
door. Not going to do that. Just going
to click on
okay. Okay. I'm supposed to turn the
ignition
off. So, we are going to start this
again. Smart key
learning. Click on okay.
Okay. So, it will populate the password
immediately and we'll just click on
okay. It will verify the password. If
you enter the password three times
wrong, it will lock the vehicle. So now
is the right time to program the key.
Once we click on okay, we have 5 seconds
to put the the head of the key on the to
contact the head of the key on the
buttons. Then the security light should
come on and go off. It means that it
will it will be programmed and it would
show on the screen that the key is
programmed. So we're going to repeat
this procedure for the aftermarket key
and hopefully our aftermarket key is
good and everything will be great. So
let's go ahead and click on
okay and
then and this worked for this
key. Remember on Hyundai Kia you have to
reprogram the original key otherwise the
key that is not programmed will be
disabled. So I'm going to say yes and do
the same thing again. I will leave that
key in the bag just in case that doesn't
work. Click okay and contact the group.
Okay, so this worked as well. It say
programming succeed. Two keys registered
into the system. Now we are going to say
okay and test the keys.
All right. So now this is our new key.
Let's go ahead and test it. It works.
Unlocks. Perfect. Let's take the
original
key. Lock. Unlock. Everything is
perfect. Now let's start the
vehicle. Vehicle starts. No problem.
And this is how you program a uh smart
key for a Hyundai
uh Santa Fe 2013 to 2017. Thanks for
watching.